let's take some phone calls here a 8:44
204 it's Trey Wingo is here I am here
Brockman's there Brockman's almost
perfect and the we came up with an idea
for my buddy Doug came up with the idea
and I decided to uncork it here the 10
best athletes since 1962 I don't know
why he chose 62 we need to find out why
we could find out from your buddy I
wonder if he's texting me like how dare
you use this because I kind of poopoo it
his idea at the poker table and then you
realize you had three hours and this is
a great idea yeah all right I know so
lists exactly
at any rate 844 204 rich is the number
to dial let's take it right now let's go
to grant in Salt Lake City you're on
with me and Trey Wingo what's up grant
rich Trey pleasure fabulous posters no
just wanted to make mention of the
Sports Illustrated issue at the end of
1999 that referenced the greatest
athletes and when voted on by other
athletes bo Jackson was far and away
considered the greatest overall athlete
of all time
and so if we're looking at it from that
context I'd put Bo top also ESPN ran a
sports science feedback 2013 poll came
out ahead there so there's a couple of
example Morpho would have to be
considered not just top 10 but top
overall so who would we take off we
would we bounce griffey jr. that that's
the game right that everyone wants to
add somebody but who are we takin off is
it jr. that should take yeah I mean yeah
yeah I think in terms of athletic
prowess bo is going to be impossible at
the top if we're talking strictly his
ability to do I'll try that and be great
at it you know I mean I mean that's he
would be difficult but I'm glad he
brought up the lists and sports science
all that stuff because remember when
Sports century came out thanks to the
call grant pretty good yeah the
controversy was where was I in front of
a horse
Secretariat I was just gonna say the
right I mean Secretariat like I'm sure
you you've wanted this you will show
people footage of secretary winning the
Belmont in 73 or the Preakness or the
Belmont won by 37 and a half lengths
whatever was be like oh that's Photoshop
no that actually happened the horse was
literally that much better than anybody
ever
we could go sports century and take
somebody that's actually gonna say tough
one to work around only six horses in
that field though yeah there was only
one let's go to Patrick in Brooklyn New
York what's up Patrick you there how're
you guys doing we're grace man is first
time long time and it it took a long
time for me to like find this
conversation and I'm arguing for ken
griffey jr. on this okay
why is that well and I don't it's the
recent color I'm not gonna try to take
bo Jackson off for any reason but if
what when I grew up ken griffey jr. was
like one of my heroes and the reason why
it's come to date now is because he was
never accused of steroids never aged
like a normal human being and he was
good for the began his career great for
a long time and then good again as he
dwindled off so I think ken griffey jr.
should be ahead of any of the Sammy Sosa
Mark McGwire or anyone in that area
appreciated Patrick thank you honey he's
aged like a normal human being how about
that funny it was 20 years ago last week
that there was the whole of the homerun
Derby right Sosa and McGwire that I I
did on the field with Stewart yep and
junior won that night yep it wasn't
McGwire who is that way right it was in
Fenway yeah junior won that contest yeah
well flat Guerrero won junior won this
kind oh my gosh
I'm happy for Pete Alonzo but he was not
amazing
let's take one more call here Brian and
Bakersfield California we're gonna go
there yeah let's go what's up Brian
you've got the floor here on the Rich
Eisen show a trailing go go for it
what's up folks you guys are talking
about Secretariat and Bo Jackson you
guys clearly missed the greatest athlete
of all time and that is Joey Chestnut
nobody even close to him in his well
category the greatest athlete ever you
know you're you're right on one level
and you're wrong on one
and that is that he and Kobayashi have
not done battle with each other for what
seven eight years now because of
different sponsorships so while you're
right
there's nobody that can challenge him in
the league that he plays in had
Kobayashi and Joey I would love to see
it right that would be the deciding
factor for this particular brand of
athletic prowess see what I'm saying
yeah see Brian I thought racing and
Bryant Brian I think what tre saying is
you got to take the the Snakepit of
competitive eating politics into account
before you thank you for the call Brian
is there anything more disgusting than
that competition well you know there's
disgusting or more America excuse me I
you don't have any children that you
know of tre you have been you're an
empty nester for a long long time for
five years
not that long yeah that long I have
three children 10 and under you are in
the zone I'm in the zone you are in the
zone so on July 4th when this is before
my two oldest went to camp
July 4th you know what you know there's
no they did something you got to do
something correct okay I showed my
children the Joey Chestnut competitive
eating thing one time much to the
consternation of Susie who you know very
well absolutely because you know it's
it's disgusting to watch but I thought
this is gonna be something my kids are
gonna get into right they were all of
them horrified by what they saw what
aspect was horrifying to them just to
see Joey Chestnut small open and close
by the way more is a very very good term
under you it is an underused term I'm
glad you brought up by the way great
fantasy team named Joey Chestnut small
yeah
the avatar is of him sticking like his a
shoe down his throat
there is absolutely didn't water so
it'll be easier to swallow
there actually is at that the Nathan's
contest something called the splash zone
right right in front of the stage from
where the stuff that doesn't quite go
down this debris
it's like hitting getting the watermelon
in the front row the Gallagher
there is a splash zone there also I'm
told is a is a different zone where
other things happen oh really yeah
where it goes it's got to come back on
now uh some people can't make it all the
way through verse no fortune that's a
different verse a fortunate some
difference very good ok the splash zone
is a real thought don't think we're
gonna remove Gretzky or Ollie and put
Joey Chestnut on this list I just got so
I think that's a decision ok let's go
one more here Andrew and Texas just
phoned in I want to get the opposite
point of view here what's up Andrew
ain't no way in the world ken griffey
jr. should be ahead of Barry Bonds Barry
Bonds hit more home runs had a higher
batting average more RBIs more stolen
bases if you take one one pitch one inch
off the plate in terms of the ball two
strikes and every pitches that you that
the other face was scared the pitch to
him he can take one pitch into and send
it over the fence well no like I said
there's no way in the world cannot
continue to the Unisphere to Barry Bonds
but Andrew you don't have any issues
with you don't have any issues with the
later part Oscar the steroids you know
have any problem with any of that Andrew
well you know you had guys in the early
part of the century
you know for spitballs and you know
using illegal substances and then during
the Hall of Fame so you know I said it
before before the UH illegal substances
he was the best player paid for 10 or 12
years you know bar none ok sure
so I said Barry Bonds it should be on
the top 10 list
Andrew thanks the call yeah there's two
lines of thought there right clearly
bonds numbers went up significantly when
he started enhancing his performance
there's no there's no debating that you
can see the numbers very late in life
the other part to his argument which i
think is very true is that there's
always been some sort of thing greenies
whatever you want to call it that people
have used to get through a hundred six
you do game schedule that's why i don't
get on this mountain and say how dare
you when there were always things that
were going on in baseball to get
somebody through 162 games okay you
ready to play this game oh yes okay I
thought that was the game no no no we
got more game
this is fun and games it's fun in games
here it's the toy department and the
rich on sanchalan game on the Callaway
corner it's just that that's a
television only gotcha
this is the simulcast all right and I'll
speak to somebody who does a simulcast
everybody you understand yes I was not
aware we have these segments that yes
then I'm on Wow you got it loaded all
right here we go
Trey Wingo versus Chris Brockman oh dear
Lee I'm going to say the name okay I'm
going to say the name and Jay get ready
to hit the drop I'm going to say the
name you will have to tell me if this
name is it is an actual name of somebody
riding in the Tour de France oh this is
great
or he's a pharmaceutical that you need
to consult your doctor before you tell
shout-out to Jean moly Dean abdul-jabbar
off my all-time great Bronson oh my
Jamaal Idina beautiful supposed to
compete with that
by the way it's early 90s by the way our
fit one of our favorite pastimes on this
show Atkin a show that's about to turn
five yes is Brockman trying to be Hooked
on Phonics by reading any sort of
results or any sort of day away from the
French Open tell you that right there
stay away from the French Open you're
probably good at the Australian and
Wimbledon even the French will slay you
just so you're aware the Tour de France
edition yeah it's an old Hey it's an old
drop okay here we go
first up first up to get do you have any
musics do you have any music no we
jumping in or we both get an answer no
it's gonna be go Brockman first than you
all right okay here we go and then I
will do my best to keep score right here
all right first up okay so gone so gone
is it a Tour de France you could turn
down the music a little bit
is it a Tour de France rider or it could
be Sagan
see I was gonna think like what do you
think Sagan I think I think that's a
rider is it a rider or pharmaceutical
well just to be a contrarian I'm gonna
go for my suit it is a writer of
Slovakian Peter cigar or Sagan
all right all right Brockman got brought
myself in fine right here we go nason
nason rider or pharmaceutical you
first Chris you got it right I think
that's a pharmaceutical what do you
think I think it's a pharmaceutic it is
a writer of belgian oliver nation
everybody he's sort of forget be a son
of a nation okay next one Makena machina
Makena see the the hawaii lover me sees
that as McKenna
okay okay sake Makenna Makenna that's a
can you go first is that or is that a
pharmaceutical or a writer I need to get
on the board I'm gonna go
that's a pharmaceutical okay I'm gonna
say Ryder it is a progestin indicated to
reduce the risk of preterm birth okay
McKenna thank you very good Amador you
go first you go next Amador that so
sounds like something you would take up
your nose I need some Amador stop by
Walgreens but I'm gonna go rider go
Rider okay I'm gonna go with trace first
instinct pharmaceutical Amador is from
Costa Rica on the movie star team
currently traverses France trades it's
the lead two to one let's go let's go
first two four
how does that sound sounds good okay
Bell Sombra that's misspoke be be Els om
RA balsam row pharmaceutical Bell samra
I am so gonna go pharmaceutic yes take
could consult your doctor before taking
bell summer which is treatment of
insomnia characterized by difficulties
with sleep onset get me some Bell song
alright so trays in front three two
right this is for the win here Trenton
Trenton Trenton New Jersey TR EE Trent
TLC the eye n is changes everything
right because it's Trenton I'm thinking
it's a rider Trenton I'm thinking with
an eyes of pharmaceutical okay what do
you think Chris I'm behind so I've got
to say rider he is from Italy oh so it's
probably it's Trentino K okay here we go
three three three three yes here we go
canasa CA na sa again spelling is
important pharmacist pharmaceutical
if you say far if you tied I've got
another tiebreaker all right I'm gonna
go Rider just to see if we get into
right here well you better take your you
definitely need to consult your doctor
before taking can assets as suppository
and treatment of heads of ulcerative and
there's a word I can't pronounce
graduations on your proctitis champion
by the way nicely the proctitis does
sound like something that bill Peter
would say he had and he couldn't go on
even situation I think he had the yellow
jersey at the first stage last year was
always great in the mountains yeah
always those mountain stages very smooth
coming down though oh my gosh for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on Direct TV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app